vous êtes sur france 24 que vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir lines est au
plus bas selon cyril ramaphosa le
président sud africain a reconnu un
recul historique lors d'une conférence
du parti affaibli en perte de vitesse
avec deux dernières élections
municipales
entre les difficultés financières et la
corruption endémique que reste-t-il du
parti historique de nelson mandela
explications à suivre
retour au calme dans les villes de l'est
de la rdc après plusieurs jours de
manifestations meurtrières pour réclamer
le départ des casques bleus jugés
inefficaces dans la lutte contre la
centaine de groupes armés responsables
chaos dans cette région mais sait-on
outreau qui se bat l'armée congolaise au
nord-kivu grands reportages à ce fil
trente militants de l'opposition ont été
libérées au bénin il avait été arrêté
lors de la période électorale de l'année
dernière une annonce aux fortunes alors
que le président français y étaient en
tournée
c'est un moment décisif pour la haine
c'est ce sont les modos cyril ramaphosa
à l'ouverture de la conférence du parti
historique sud africain celui de nelson
mandela au plus bas battus dans les
dernières élections terriblement divisés
le parti de la haine c'est vit ses
dernières heures les hommes plus
difficiles entre les difficultés
financières et la corruption endémique
dans le pays notre correspondante
caroline dumay a suivi pour nous
l'ouverture de la conférence à
johannesbourg
[Applaudissements]
l'un des sujets les plus délicats qui
sera abordé par les deux mille délégués
de la haine c'est ce week-end c'est
celui de la corruption et le président
cyril ramaphosa n'a pas l'intention de
l'enterrer
nous laissons souvent des choses très
mauvaise continuer pendant très
longtemps
de la corruption des services municipaux
défaillant un management pauvres
sans jamais qu'il n'y ait aucune
conséquence
c'est la fraude et la corruption qui au
final volts à notre peuple les services
de base auxquels ils ont droit
camarades on doit en finir cette
conférence doit traiter de ce problème
la direction de l'insee a confirmé que
plus de 200 membres étaient impliqués
dans des affaires de corruption dans le
rapport du juge dando actuellement il ya
une clause de mise à l'écart ou tout
membre de la haine ces inculpés doit
quitter ses fonctions
je m'attends à ce que ce sujet soit
largement débattus à cette conférence
vous avez vu que dans le rapport rondeau
la nc est mentionné de façon désagréable
notre devoir en tant que leader de la nc
et d'aborder cette réalité frontalement
est d'arriver à trouver des solutions
pour améliorer cette situation aux
pauvres avoir touché pour certaines
délégations cette clause de mise à
l'écart est trop dure pour d'autres elle
n'est pas assister vers le pays tout
entier s'attend à ce que la haine c est
une position claire sur ce sujet on
passe à la république démocratique du
congo le calme est revenu ce vendredi
dans l'est du pays après plusieurs jours
de manifestations meurtrières pour
réclamer le départ des forces onusiennes
accusées d'être inefficace dans la lutte
contre la centaine de groupes armés
responsables du chaos qui règne dans la
région écoutez ces manifestants
déterminés à poursuivre leur combat mais
lucide
nous sommes toujours déterminés nous
sommes en train de mener à la monusco de
sortir de notre pays en tout cas nous
sommes prêts à mourir tous
mon point de vue c'est que les gens qui
ont marché ont pris une bonne décision
il est malheureusement ils n'ont pas
réussi à atteindre leur but car si
jamais la monusco ne part pas ça sera
comme si rien n'avait été fait ma main
cette guerre dans l'est de la rdc qui
dure depuis 25 ans est responsable de la
mort de plusieurs centaines de milliers
à plusieurs millions de personnes mais
que savons nous des forces en présence
contre qui l'armée congolaise autres se
battent elles au nord kivu c'est la
question que se posent certains
observateurs depuis la résurgence du m23
le groupe armé à dominante tutsie la rdc
accuse le rwanda de les soutenir ce que
kigali dément grand reportage de clément
bonnerot et justin kalumba
sur cette colline les miliciens du m23
tient leur position on les voit avec
leurs armes ils ont des mitrailleuses
12.7 nous sommes à trois kilomètres de
la ligne de front près du pont
stratégique de roanne guba à 25 km de la
frontière avec l'ouganda depuis un mois
l'armée congolaise a renforcé ses
effectifs pour contenir l'avancée des
rebelles l'ennemi que nous avons en face
de nous a des armes lourdes des mortiers
des mitrailleuses
nous aussi nous avons des armes comme
pour défendre notre position pour éviter
qu'ils arrivent jusqu ici nombre des
frais fait déjà deux fois qu'on les a
attaqués et qu'on a réussi à les
repousser depuis la résurgence du m23
fin novembre l'armée congolaise s'étonne
de voir les miliciens aussi bien armés
et équipés de groupes avaient pourtant
été défait en 2013 puis démobilisé pour
les faire des c pas de doute eu 23
bénéficie du soutien des pays voisins au
fur et à mesure que nous sommes en train
kottak avec l'aîné mais on s'est rendu
compte
que c'était bel et bien
l'armée rwandaise
qui appuyé
cet ennemi était que la guerre qu'elles
ont mené ces groupes armés antoine était
kinga par procuration il y a dix ans le
rwanda soutenait déjà le m23 et avait
été publiquement condamné par l'onu
aujourd'hui l'armée congolaise accuse
aussi kigali d'intervenir directement
sur son sol et présentent ce qu'elle
décrit comme des preuves comme ces
photos de drone montrant des soldats
avant sans colonne en pleine nuit ou
encore ses armes et ses équipements
retrouvez sur le champ de bataille vous
voyez que ce sont le board des rwanda
différence fausses nous avons récupéré
tout ça
lors de nos batailles ça ce sont des
casques utilisé par les unités spéciales
formaient deux soldats rwandais avait
aussi été arrêté au nord kivu avant
d'être libéré et remis à kigali
ni l'ambassadeur du rwanda en rdc ni le
porte parole de l'armée rwandaise n'ont
souhaité répondre à nos questions
toute accusation contre accuse action de
cette nature ne peut être vérifié que
par le biais du mécanisme conjoint de
vérification élargie et non par des
déclarations dans les médias
dans leur dernier rapport publié en juin
les experts de l'onu ont quant à eux
confirmé la présence de militaires
rwandais dans des camps du m23 en rdc
évoquant des images aériennes et des
preuves photographiques
30 militants de l'opposition béninoise
ont été libérés ce mercredi il avait été
arrêté pendant la présidentielle d'avril
2021 l'annoncé a été faite alors que le
président français y étaient en visite
officielle à cotonou emmanuel sodji a
recueilli quelques réactions
c'est la troisième fois que la justice
libère des militants de l'opposition
mais cette fois ci c'est la plus grosse
vague de libération alors parmi les
trente personnes il ya notamment la
jeune activiste nadine houkouma sous
l'ancien ministre ou du wali ou encore
un des vice présidents du parti
d'opposition les démocrates paulin dos à
ces personnes sont à présent sous
contrôle judiciaire
l'annoncé de leur libération est tombé
au même moment que le passage du
président français au bénin mais c'est
une forte coïncidence selon les
autorités mais je peux vous dire que
c'est un peu has had calendrier la
justice fonctionne
son timing suivant son agenda et cette
vague de libération de personnes
arrêtées à l'occasion ou après la
présidentielle dès 2022 pour des faits
liés à la à des tentatives de
déstabilisation du pays qui leur étaient
reprochés
il se trouve que ces personnes sont
arrivés à une phase de l'enquète pour la
justice a estimé utile de les élargir et
de la placer sous convocation le temps
que le procès se tienne il reste encore
des dizaines de personnes des militants
de l'opposition en prison et parmi eux
deux célèbres leaders le juriste joël
aïvo condamné à dix ans de prison et
l'ancien garde des sceaux reckya
madougou 20 ans de prison pour elles
sont vraiment aux détenus politiques
qu'on le veuille ou non c'est ça le mot
donc aussi doivent être libérés par
monsieur pat et talent l'opposition
demande à présent que le chef de l'état
patrice talon aille plus loin en faisant
par exemple voter une loi d'amnistié ou
un geste de clémence de sa part ce sont
les otages la façon dont ils ont été
libérés c'est comme ça on libère des
otages quoique nous disait rien n'est
fini merci au chef de l'état pour sa
volonté politique manifeste ça prouve à
suffisance les seuls à pouvoir trouver
la solution à cette crise que nous
vivons depuis 2007 depuis plusieurs mois
on assiste à une baisse des tensions
dans le pays et cela depuis que les
ennemis politiques l'ancien président
boni yayi et patrice talon ont repris
contact d'ailleurs à l'issue de leur
dernière rencontre en juin dernier dix
sept personnes avaient été libérées
cinq enfants de l'ancien président
gabonais omar bongo dont sa fille aînée
pascaline ont été mises en examen à
paris dans le dossier dit des biens mal
acquis ils sont soupçonnés d'avoir
profité du patrimoine immobilier
frauduleusement je le cite acquis en
france par leurs pairs évalué récemment
à au moins 85 millions d' or on
vous en parlait ce jeudi les ministres
de l'énergie de l'algérie du nigeria et
du niger ont signé un accord pour un
projet de gazoduc transsaharien un
projet réactivé à cause de la guerre en
ukraine seulement il est en péril avant
même sa mise en oeuvre insécurité
volatilité de la situation politique et
corruption correspondance d'aral tir à
plus de 4000 km d'installation au moins
10 milliards de dollars
d'investissements et des ambitions
gigantesque en termes de capacité de
mettre deux cubes de gaz transportable
le projet de gazoduc transsaharien est
un projet pharaonique qui a rassemblé
ces trois pays autour d'un mot
concrétiser ce projet existe depuis 2009
il avait été lancée à ce moment là mais
il reste aujourd'hui encore un défi de
taille le gazoduc prendra sa source dans
les zones les plus au sud du nigeria les
zones gazière et passera ensuite par le
nord du pays l'une des zones les plus
dangereuses au monde car en proie
régulièrement aux violences et
djihadistes et criminel le 'pipeline'
passera ensuite par le niger et
traversera plusieurs zones d'insécurité
avant de rejoindre l'algérie par une
frontière poreuse une frontière sujet
elle aussi à l'insécurité mais aussi aux
trafics en tout genre depuis de
nombreuses années une fois fonctionnels
les installations desserviront d'abord
les régions par lesquelles elles
passeront avant de passer par le
'pipeline' déjà existant en algérie pour
desservir l'europe mais aussi par voie
navale mais le principal sujet de
préoccupation pour les autorités de ces
trois pays qui veulent faire aboutir ce
projet pour l'instant c'est de pouvoir
sécuriser un chantier long de trois pays
pour l'instant aucune date précise n'a
été annoncée par les autorités d'aucun
de ces pays pour une fin éventuelle de
ce futur chantier c'est la fin de ce
journal merci à tous ceux qui nous ont
suivis partout au sénégal de dakar à
fadiouth à 5 me en passant par thiès
kaolack ziguinchor
on s'y retrouve pour les législatives en
attendant restez avec nous car
l'actualité continue sur france 24
[Musique]